corresponding
a California man now faces multiple
charges after opening fire on sheriff's
deputies and leading investigators on a
foot chase through Compton at about 10
30 a.m on January 31st Los Angeles
County sheriff's deputies were searching
for 36-year-old Mario bustillo for an
outstanding no bail warrant on a
violation of his post-release community
supervision bustillo had previously been
convicted of multiple charges including
assault vehicle Theft Grand Theft felon
in possession of a firearm and
possession of Narcotics paraphernalia
when sheriff's deputy is found bustillo
in the neighborhood of his last known
address he shot at them after that
dispatch received a 9-1-1 call
yeah they are they are but if you hear
anything
where where
the caller can be heard explaining
bustillo is hiding in their garage
do you still see him
yeah inside
yeah
after this Los Angeles County sheriff's
deputies request backup from special
enforcement Bureau Personnel including a
helicopter response during what
officials call a barricade operation
Lucille runs from the garage security
video catches him running through a
backyard and scaling a wall to evade
capture after this he fires shots at two
separate deputies and three officials
return fire multiple First Responders
were wearing body cameras at the time
but did not activate them until after
the shooting that means video of the
shots fired was captured on body cam but
audio was not recorded until after the
shooting
[Applause]
just south of the Black Hills one
property
camera video from another sheriff's
deputy shows another angle of the
post-shooting response hey I'm watching
upstairs I got eyes on him
making contact
investigators say bustillo was shot in
the Torso he was treated on the scene
and later taken to the hospital
officials later recovered a 40 caliber
semi-automatic gun with an extended
magazine on the scene bustillo now faces
multiple charges including five counts
of attempted murder of a peace officer
the officer involved shooting is now
under investigation by the Los Angeles
County Sheriff's department and the Los
Angeles County District Attorney's
Office reporting for long crime Network
I'm Sierra Gillespie